a part of me is part of me is glad is
that you i have like youtube to keep me
in check almost
not that i would start doing awful [ __ ]
if i wasn't a youtuber
but the fact that there is this kind of
like obvious moral lines that right
that it's not like oh no man should i
show you no no it's not they're like
these unspoken guidelines and rules to
like make sure you're not
right yeah it really makes me cautious
about how i come up to people and what i
say to people makes me way more
conscious about how i speak
in a way that i think is you know i the
way i speak on
live streams the way i speak you know on
the video is how i'll speak to
most people in my life and how yeah you
know and i like that
it's kind of taught me in a way to just
it sounds awful right but just give a
[ __ ] about everything
and pay attention even if it is draining
at times sounds awful i'm like yeah you
should taught me to be
not an [ __ ] like but like you know
how some things you take for granted
yeah that you when you're you know when
you're an individual who isn't like uh
open person yeah i mean for me it's it's
not it didn't teach me to you know give
a [ __ ] about everything but it did teach
me to really
question my own values yeah and
and really justify if is is this value i
hold right
right as opposed to like i just think
about
i just think it this way because i was i
grew up in that kind of environment
and it really made me self-reflect and i
feel like that that is like
a healthy part of youtube that has has i
think i've become
a better person because of youtube yeah
like it's it's about that mentality of
like okay if i wasn't doing youtube then
do is the things that i do and the way
that i talk to people and what kind of
stuff
would that be still considered
respectful to other people
regardless of if i if i had this job or
not like would i still be a good person
if i didn't have youtube
and if the answer is yes then i think
you're following it right if you're
worrying if the answer is no
yeah well i mean you know look at all
the douche tubers right apparently you
can get away with that [ __ ] if you have
a youtube channel
i don't know do they get away with that
[ __ ] though like i mean i mean there's a
reason why they have an audience are
they are they
on borrowed time are they like a twit
longer waiting to happen
because they're definitely like a limit
like they're not going to be like
at the point that they are for very long
because i feel like a big
i mean this is getting to a really deep
topic now but a big problem with
a lot of these like apology videos and
you know
a lot of this kind of culture that has
been built up i understand where it
comes from where we we do need to keep
in
uh we do need to keep each other in
check and make sure that people aren't
abusing their power
but a part of it just makes me feel like
man people are just treating this like
one big reality tv show
it's not keeping each other checked
we've just made it a modern coliseum
yeah yeah we just we just gamified it
basically yeah we've just you know
we can't kill each other that's the best
thing we can do is [ __ ] get at each
other's throats
yeah which is which is why right now now
when i see an apology video or twit
longer
you know like a lot a lot of like as we
said we were taught to you know have to
give a [ __ ] about this thing
but sometimes i see this and i'm like i
don't have the energy to keep the [ __ ]
to care about this this doesn't involve
me you know sometimes
it it it [ __ ] sucks when i when i
hear about
you know some some person in the
community or in some community
that i'm not even involved with doing
like having like a five
five fifty page more like 50 page
dissertation breaking down every shitty
thing they've done
and i'm like i'm sorry but this happened
but at the same time
like i don't have the energy to invest
myself into this
can someone literally give me a cliff
notes of what's going on and you're like
i don't want to be the guy to be like
can you tell me what to think
but there there reaches a point where
there is too much happening right now
that
you can you can it's it's it's it's like
sensory overload
yeah this is like at the end of the day
all i'm seeing is someone's getting
[ __ ] paid leave that's all i'm seeing
yeah it's like i have limited time i
have limited energy and i want to be
able to use it on [ __ ] i actually
care about yeah yeah like i i would like
to care about every big scandal
every big thing that gets you know
brought up on twitter and
you know that's that logically and if i
think about it that's what i want to
value but
logistically you can't you can't you
can't care about this much [ __ ]
and i feel like a big problem right now
is that
this this entire environment just feels
like
big brother or this feels like a real
reality tv show where
people care but do they really care like
they get to a point where
this is really where i think does this
really involve me does this
you know am i am i doing something right
to society by getting involved with this
or am i just feeding the fumes and the
fire and just making the environment
more toxic
you have thick enough skin nothing's
stopping
if you don't care that everyone hates
you yeah and you're fine with that
there's literally nothing stopping you
from succeeding i mean there's people
who
make a career off of being hated right
so funny
yeah yeah i mean it's one of the biggest
examples of course logan paul
and one of i i can't remember who said
this quote but
it was you know i think it was like
muhammad ali or
a boxer where they say well they said
something like
if uh people will pay to like
what was it people will pay to watch you
to shut you up
yeah people will pay to watch you get
punched yeah
or whatever logan paul has capitalized
that
to the max i mean i i i'll [ __ ] admit
you know
you know i i got involved with whenever
logan paul gets and uh gets into a
boxing match
of course i did i want to see logan paul
get punched yeah she's funny you know i
mean
i don't really have anything personally
against the guy obviously but like it's
just
fun seeing to usually smack each other
in the face it's funny as [ __ ]
yeah yeah i'd do that if the right
target came up i'm like yo how much
money did he make
put me in the ring y'all give me some
beef please
give me some beef to fight over here
yeah like
god yeah that's scary how it's evolved
yeah that point isn't it it's like it
makes you wonder what the next step is
like we're going we're going back to
where we started where you know when
reality is this entertaining
who the [ __ ] needs tv that's what i've
been saying the whole time gone
reality has always been more
entertaining documentaries yeah man you
can't make this [ __ ] up man you
you can make up all these harry potters
all and all the rings that's
epic and all i love those films but
can't make up the weird [ __ ] that
happens in real life